I'm writing every Devil's fruit in one
piece to figure out which is the best
one this is the middle meronomi which
lets the user turn people into stone it
was eaten by Boa Hancock the princess of
Amazon Lily and for strength the user
can turn anyone into stone as long as
the target Fields some desire for their
user so make sure to keep those dirty
thoughts hidden a heart-throbbing 20 out
of 25 points but absolutely zero points
for defense the special abilities this
fruit makes its user a top tier
negotiator because if your lustful crew
is turned into stone the user can demand
whatever they want or you crew will
never live again 20 points however this
fruit is not super practical for
everyday use unless you're like crazy
handsome or super attractive or
something my points and it also does
have some major intimacy issues because
someone must be attracted to the user
for the powers to work if they just
don't think that you're hot or they stab
themselves to drive away those thoughts
you are out of luck mine is 15 points
for that bringing the total to a
Loveless 30 points and off of the podium
for good